il aurait fallu des années d'une guerre
acharnée pour jeter à terre les 14
siècles qui ont façonné la ville
d'Antioche le séisme de février dernier
n'a mis que quelques instants pour
effacer le passé et pour année en tir le
présent de milliers de famille ici
on peut pas dormir on revit le séisme
dans nos rêves dit Elise
des morts-vivants c'est ce qu'ils sont
devenus depuis les six heures qu'ils ont
passé enseveli sous les décombres une
éternité à attendre de l'aide pendant
que leur fils se vidait de son sang ses
baratine était inconscient la jambe
coincée
je voulais la couper alors j'ai tiré
pour l'arracher mais elle était coincée
jusqu'au genou sous les escaliers
ont aussi perdu un petit-fils et un
gendre leur vie se résume désormais à
cette tente autour de laquelle
s'articule une existence qui n'a plus de
sens
[Musique]
dans les champs de ruines qui est devenu
Antioche ce dont la maison n'est pas
complètement effondrée revienne pour
prendre quelques affaires que la terre
n'a pas englouti mermed a tout perdu
sauf la foi et le sourire
nous avons une tente nous avons
l'opportunité de manger il distribue de
l'eau et de la nourriture sans cesse
c'est tout ce qui compte dans la vie
on ne voit presque pas d'afficher
électorale Antioche encore faudrait-il
trouver des murs ou les accrocher mais
les vestiges du tremblement de terre qui
a fait plus de 50 000 morts dans 11
villes dans le sud-est du pays pèse
lourd dans la campagne électorale
le gouvernement d'erdohann a été
durement critiqué pour sa gestion des
opérations de secours en février
on reproche aussi au président d'avoir
failli à mettre en place des règles
strictes de construction alors que les
risques étaient connus dans un pays qui
a vécu plusieurs séismes dévastateurs
tout ça ne branle pas la confiance de
mes maîtres envers le Président
le gouvernement au pouvoir fait de
grandes promesses et jusqu'ici ils ont
tenu toute leur promesses
qu'il soutiennent le gouvernement ou les
parties d'opposition le plus grand défi
de la tenue d'un scrutin maintenant dans
les zones dévastées par le tremblement
de terre ce sera pour les électeurs de
trouver un bureau de scrutin la très
grande majorité des gens qui ont été
affectés ont trouvé refuge dans des
villes à des centaines de kilomètres de
là où ils peuvent voter
la machine politique le sait et se
prépare faire sortir le vote n'aura
jamais impliqué autant d'efforts au
moins un million de déplacés devront
compter sur un transport offert par les
parties le jour du vote
impossible de prédire combien ferons le
long voyage vers des villes qui ne
seraient les abriter
dans le Grand Bazar d'Antioche les
débris jonchent toujours les passages
qui donnent sur des rideaux de fer tirer
seulement quelques commerces ont ouvert
leurs portes
Kadir prie pour que ça change rapidement
j'ai 47 ans et j'ai vécu ici toute ma
vie jamais on aurait imaginé voir cet
endroit dans cet état partout c'est
dévasté
mais lui n'en tient pas rigueur au
Président erdan il peut encore compter
sur son appui ce qui compte la survie du
pays c'est la stabilité
il connaît tout de cette voiture de son
moteur sa mécanique tout si cette
voiture tombe en panne le propriétaire
va savoir ce qui ne va pas il va le
réparer
Méral n'a rien vu passer de la campagne
électorale son mari et elle sont sans
eau et sans électricité depuis trois
mois comment s'informer de ce qui se
passe
ça ne va pas l'empêcher de voter devant
la tante et la planté la même où
s'élever sa maison détruite cette
grand-mère qui a perdu trois petits fils
refusent de dire ouvertement qui est le
soutien et que les choses changent se
contentent-elles de dire
on sait qui s'est précipité pour nous
les gens ne sont plus naïfs dit-elle
les langues se sont déliées dans la
colère après le tremblement de terre
mais les critiques à l'endroit du
gouvernement se font encore aujourd'hui
en message codé
il y a des gens à nos côtés pour nous
soutenir jour et nuit quand nous ne
trouvons pas le sommeil ils sont là on
ne peut pas leur tourner le dos
ce dont parle c'est baratine ce sont les
employés de la mairie d'Istanbul le
maire de la ville n'est pas candidat
mais c'est un grand rival du président
erdan presque tous ses voisins
d'infortune partage son opinion
affirme-t-il c'est sans doute exagéré
encore des appuis indéfectibles ici sur
la ligne de faille mais en 20 ans de
pouvoir à l'image du sol ici il n'a
jamais été aussi fragilisé